thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler right now north las vegas
police are looking for the driver who
hit and killed a man
who was waiting at a bus stop overnight
this happened on las vegas boulevard
near pecos hector mejia
is live at the scene right now with the
latest on the case hector
well this is the second deadly hit and
run for investigators just in the last
two days in this incident
no information yet about the driver who
police believe was traveling along these
northbound lanes of las vegas boulevard
hit the bus stop and killed a man here
near belmont
north las vegas police say they were
called just after one o'clock this
morning but it was too late
the victim had already died his name has
not been released
but we are told he was in his 40s also
police have not said whether they know
anything about the car
or the suspect behind the wheel in this
case we do have new information about a
separate hit and run crash from saturday
the coroner identified destiny jackson
as the 22 year old pedestrian
who was killed who was killed near fort
apache in charleston
the driver in that case 69 year old
richard modolo also left the scene but
was later tracked down by detectives
he was booked into the detention center
however he has already been released by
a judge
and placed on high level electronic
monitoring
is going back to court on april 19th and
back to this incident in north las vegas
authorities say that details are still
limited we'll let you know as soon as
they uncover
anything new about what happened here
near this bus stop reporting in north
las vegas hector mejia
8 news now